We had said that the title of this
lesson is Common Sense Reasoning, but
let's dig a little bit deeper so
that we can see where the common
sense reasoning is coming here.
Consider the sentence,
Ashok put the wedge on the block.
Imagine an agent that
pulls out the frame for
move-object with a primitive action and
fills in all of these slots.
And by now we know how
the agent can do that.
I were to ask the agent,
did Ashok's hand move when he was
putting the wedge on the block?
I would expect the agent to say,
yes, because that is what happens when
people move the wedge to the block.
They grasp their hands around the wedge,
they move their hand,
then they release their fingers.
Now this is what common sense
reasoning is about, making inferences
that are not necessarily part
of the input sentence here, but
are part of the background
knowledge that the agent has.
So the agent can make
inferences about the world,
common sense inferences about the world.
So the question then becomes, what is
the knowledge that an agent must have so
that it can, in fact, make the kind of
inferences that we are talking about,
common sense inferences?
Suppose that the agent had not only
knowledge of the primitive action
move-object, but
also about some of the sub-actions.
So here are some of the sub-actions for
the human context.
So in the context of moving wedges and
blocks,
the agent might already
have a kind of micro-story.
Which says that when
actions get done and
things get moved from one
place to another place,
then typically fingers are first
closed around the first object.
Then the hand moves and the fingers
are released around the second object.
>> So Ashok, if we can decompose
move-object into a series of
move-body-part actions, was
move-object really a primitive action?
>> That's a valid question, David.
Move-object was indeed a primitive
action related to the various
superficial forms in which words can
occur in a sentence, as an example,
transported, carried, or moved.
However, this primitive action
move-object can have its own story
in terms of further decomposition.
Notice this particular decomposition,
this particular story is specific to
the structure of the sentence where
Ashok puts the wedge on the block.
This raises lots of hard issues.
How many such stories are there?
Do we have a story?
Must an agent have such a story for
every single situation
that it encounters?
Those are hard questions, and
it's not clear that currently hasn't
answered all of those questions.
So this theory by no
means covers all stories,
many of the stories are beyond
the scope of this theory.
And in fact, even for
the stories that are within this scope,
there is a hard question about
computational tractability,
because a number of such stories
can explode very quickly.